all right don mccarthy of dawn's corner
has some great products founded created
or developed
by women in honor of women's history
month take a look
hi las vegas now first up i have
products for the fur kids in the family
susie cbd treats was created by three
entrepreneurs
under 30 back in 2016 who saw how much
cbd helped their dog susie as she aged
and they knew they had to make these
organic and human grade products
available
to all people and pets in need they have
peanut butter for dogs cbd bites for
cats
the trees which are one of their best
sellers come in original
pumpkin and apple and the cbd oil is
from colorado hemp
they give 10 of their profits back to
shelters across the usa
and standby we know it works because we
tried it on ourselves first
then we gave it to our pets check out
suziespettreats.com
i don't know about you but i love
anything personalized or
gemstones and with tough as a mother
tribe you get both created by jennifer
cervantes a former teacher and
mompreneur
she knew she wanted to create jewelry
that had meaning and purpose
she creates custom initial necklaces
that are perfect pieces if you are
seeking quality jewelry
at affordable prices i have something
for our new mama lindsey
or mom mercedes and i had jennifer
create something for selena
these pieces make the perfect new mom
gift baby shower gift
or gift for yourself i am wearing the d
and j for me and my fur kid josie
jennifer believes you are strong
beautiful and tough as a mother and
let's face it moms are working overtime
these days
so embrace your journey go to
toughestmothertribe.com
now for the past 20 years brie mccarthy
who created and founded brie on brows
has been obsessed with all things brows
my favorite go-to on her site is her
three-step brow and lash bundle
she created an eyelash scrub that you
use one to two times a week yes i said a
scrub to clean your brows
follow that up with lash nectar which is
a two-in-one product for your lashes
and brows it's formulated with powerful
peptides vitamins
amino acids coconut and sesame seed oil
and lastly the liquid gold brow
oil to finish up this is going to work
naturally to strengthen the brow hairs
and encourage hair
growth use these products nightly to
take your brows from sparse
to spectacular thank you brianne brows
now to the first all black owned energy
drink company goat fuel this is a family
operated energy drink company
co-founded by nfl hall of famer jerry
rice hence the goat
for greatest of all time and his
daughter jaquie rice who serves as a ceo
and co-founder this vegan gluten-free
energy drink is uniquely powered by
cordyceps mushrooms
which are known for anti-aging improving
oxygen
and reducing inflammation boasted by
natural caffeine and green tea to give
you a clean boost of energy
as well as 10 essential vitamins to
improve recovery this beverage has
zero sugar and zero preservatives goat
fuel currently has four flavors which
include blueberry lemonade
peach pineapple tropical berry and pink
candy i say try them all
i can't choose a favorite go to
gofuel.com for more information
lastly to a company that's all about
girl power moxie-chic.com
founded in july 2019 by native new
yorker mother jen
moxie chic is a brand of feminist
apparel and accessories with unique
designs
aimed at empowering and celebrating
women and girls of all ages
with a bolt a positive energy the array
of designs and options say it all from
t-shirts to hats to bathing suits
to mommy and me there's something to
empower every girl or woman
jen also donates money from every sale
to organizations supporting women and
girls
they don't just talk about girl power
they support it
moxie chic wants every girl to embrace
her moxie be her best self
and change the world happy women's
history month for more information on
any of these products go to
donscorner.com